Sean bienvenidos a un nuevo episodio de
historia en France 24 Mi nombre es
Álvaro cordero Este 19 de abril de 2023
se cumple el 80 aniversario de uno de
los episodios más recordados de la
Segunda Guerra Mundial en Polonia el
alzamiento de los judíos en el gueto de
Varsovia un combate sin precedentes
contra la ocupación de la Alemania nazi
que fue el último aliento de resistencia
de la población judía polaca que llevaba
años siendo exterminada para ese momento
y que tras este evento prácticamente
desapareció de Polonia antes de la
Segunda Guerra Mundial Polonia era un
país muy diferente al actual además de
tener unas fronteras diferentes a las de
hoy en día el país estaba más hacia el
este y tenía una población mucho más
heterogénea además se estima que para
1939 había unos 33 millones de polacos
la mayoría de ellos católicos como en la
actualidad pero un 10 % es decir 3
millones 300.000 eran de origen judío
estas personas llevaban en Polonia cerca
de ocho siglos y eran parte fundamental
de la sociedad polaca al desarrollar
empleos tan acomodados como el de Joyero
banquero profesor o abogado
pero su situación comenzó a cambiar el 1
de septiembre de 1939 ese día inició la
invasión de la Alemania nazi a Polonia Y
aunque el gobierno polaco intentó
resistir con ayuda de su población judía
y católica en un principio finalmente
colapsó ante la fuerza alemana a partir
de ahí los judíos empezaron a sufrir una
serie de violaciones y sus derechos que
culminaron con el reasentamiento de
todos los judíos en guetos una especie
de barrios amurallados en el centro de
las principales ciudades polacas estas
ciudades eran Varsovia cracovia lubling
o Lots luego ya a partir de 1942 de
mediados de ese año es Cuando comenzó el
traslado hacia campos de Exterminio como
auschwich o treblinka poniendo así las
llamadas solución final implementada por
los nazis
el de Varsovia era el mayor gueto en
toda Europa en su máxima apogeo llegó a
albergar a casi 400.000 judíos de la
capital y los alrededores y dentro de
sus muros de 18 kilómetros de extensión
se vivía en condiciones infrahumanas de
hacinamiento y proliferación de
enfermedades que provocaron la muerte de
miles de personas especialmente de
ancianos y niños a ello había que
sumarle la falta de alimentación y
condiciones límite de trabajo
en el siguiente mapa podemos observar la
localización de este gueto un espacio en
el que podemos ver que está dividido en
dos grandes partes una más grande y otra
de menor tamaño la parte de mayor tamaño
es donde estaban los judíos que eran
hábiles para trabajar y la parte de
menor tamaño es donde se ubicó a
aquellas personas que serían las que
primero llegarían a esos campos de
Exterminio
250.000 judíos del gueto fueron
deportados entre julio y noviembre de
1942 a este campo de treblinka sin
apenas resistencia ya que pensaban que
iban a trabajar treblinka a diferencia
de auschwich no era un campo de
concentración Solamente era un sitio de
Exterminio y las personas que llegaban a
él eran automáticamente asesinadas es en
este contexto en el que la población
restante del gueto que para ese entonces
era de unos 60.000 ante la falta de
noticias de sus familiares y amigos
deportados y las informaciones
suministradas por espías polacos sobre
el campo de treblinka se dieron cuenta
que estaban siendo exterminados y
comenzaron a organizarse desde inicios
de 1943 dos organizaciones judías
tomaron el control la izquierdista
organización judía de combate y la
derechista unión militar judía ambas
mantuvieron relación con la resistencia
polaca Católica y estos comenzaron a
suministrar al gueto armamento y
explosivos el objetivo primordial era
evitar deportaciones y terminar con el
control nazi dentro del gueto algo que
lograron en esos primeros meses del año
1943 y que llevó a que Berlín enviase a
miles de soldados a retomar el gueto
iniciando los combates el 19 de abril de
1943 la resistencia judía sorprendió a
los alemanes que se vieron obligados a
destruir casa por casa y sufrieron
numerosas bajas Durante los 27 días que
duró la sublevación a pesar de que las
organizaciones judías estaban mal
equipadas el hecho de que la mayoría de
los judíos restantes en el gueto fueran
hombres jóvenes cuyas familias habían
sido asesinadas los hizo combatir sin
tener nada que perder el sistema de
búnkers y de guerra de guerrillas puso
al límite a las fuerzas alemanas que
tuvieron más de 1000 fallecidos Aunque
finalmente el 16 de mayo el general
jürgen dio por finalizadas las
operaciones
en total 7.000 judíos fallecieron en los
combates y otros 6000 se suicidaron o
murieron en los incendios el resto unos
40.000 fueron trasladados al campo de
Exterminio de trevinca donde allí fueron
asesinados
los alemanes celebraron el fin de la
presencia judía en Varsovia con la
destrucción de la mayor sinagoga de la
capital la Alemania nazi fue la
responsable del Exterminio del 90% de la
población judía que vivía en Polonia y
los pocos sobrevivientes huyeron a
Israel al final de la contienda la
ocupación alemana en Varsovia No duraría
mucho más en 1944 comenzó el alzamiento
de Varsovia de los polacos católicos que
se saldó con más de 250.000 muertos y el
83% de la capital arrasada hasta que las
tropas soviéticas liberaron a la ciudad
a inicios de 1945 con esto concluimos
Gracias por compartir y comentar estas
historias que las encuentran en los
programas de France 24.com
[Música]